bonsoir solène vous êtes à lyon pas très
loin des deux là où l'agression s'est
produite que sait-on ce soir de cette
affaire et bien cet après midi à 16h à
un prêtre orthodoxe a reçu deux coups de
fusil à l'abdomen alors qu'il était en
train de fermer son église dans le 7e
arrondissement de lyon où nous nous
trouvons il est actuellement hospitalisé
son pronostic vital est engagé
un périmètre de sécurité est installé
dans le quartier aux alentours de
l'église
selon les premiers éléments révélés par
la police son agresseur serait un homme
d'une quarantaine d'années il était armé
d'un fusil à canon scié un suspect
répondant à cette description a été
interpellé par la police nationale vers
20 heures
ils ne portaient pas d'armes il est
actuellement en garde à vue pour
l'instant nous n'avons aucune
information sur son identité ni sur le
mobile de cette attaque
son implication dans cette attaque reste
encore à confirmer
le parquet de lyon a ouvert une enquête
pour assassinat de son côté le parquet
antiterroriste lui continue d'évaluer la
sphère et le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin a ouvert une cellule de
crise en lien avec le premier ministre
et le président de la république
merci beaucoup solène pour toutes ces
précisions soleil mme godin en direct de
lyon